a disturbing new Pentagon report
indicates sexual assault at three
prestigious u.s. military academies
spiked fifty percent in the past school
year an estimated seven hundred and
forty-seven West Point and Air Force
Academy cadets and Naval Academy
Midshipmen told an anonymous survey they
were sexually assaulted in the last
academic year now that's up from five
hundred seven three years ago the survey
also found worsening problems at the Air
Force Academy
despite changes put in place after our
reporting exposed troubling patterns
Defense Department officials say they
are troubled and disheartened by the
surge in sexual harassment and violence
at US military service academies
according to a new survey released
Thursday fifty percent of the women and
sixteen percent of the men enrolled at
the military Air Force and naval
academies were sexually harassed another
16 percent of the women and two percent
of the men say they were sexually
assaulted there is a cultural rot it's
not just a few bad apples congresswoman
Jackie Speier chairs the House
Subcommittee on military personnel I
think some heads have to roll if all of
a sudden these cadets are going to be
kicked out and their families are going
to be expected to pay $100,000 in
tuition maybe the halia will change at
the Air Force Academy approximately 221
cadets reported they were sexually
assaulted up from a hundred and fifty
two years ago in 2017 we spoke to more
than a dozen current and former Air
Force Academy cadets who said they were
retaliated against after reporting their
assaults you go there because you want
to protect your country and they they
don't protect you
do you regret reporting the assault
[Music]
nationwide nearly 750 cadets and
Midshipmen said in an anonymous survey
they were sexually assaulted last year
but only 92 formally reported it
accountability is the missing element
and
all of this Don Christiansen a retired
colonel and former Air Force chief
prosecutor says just four people accused
of sexual assault at the Academy's last
year were convicted each one of the
academies has a three-star who oversees
that they are literally the only person
who can prosecute the case
you know they simply do not send enough
people to court and that is part of the
big problem the Pentagon says this
report does not reflect the impact of
prevention programs implemented last
year an army secretary Marquez first
says he has directed West Point's
leadership to come up with an updated
action plan in the coming weeks the Air
Force Academy told CBS this morning we
remain committed to tackling this issue
head-on we worked diligently to create
new programs adjust existing ones in
order to better serve our cadets and let
me tell you we're gonna stay on this
because to me when I met those women who
are the best and the brightest the
toughest women I have ever met
the fact that they were assaulted
harassed and then put through it again
by our service Academy Chiefs generals
who are in charge simply unacceptable we
need the best people in our services to
serve and it looks had the right to
serve I don't think we're gonna hear
more pressure from Congress well the
heads need to roll the gap between those
who have experienced it and those who've
been able to report it it's just it's
fast it's fast and so I do I do give the
Pentagon a lot of props for being open
and transparent about this for having an
anonymous survey so we can try and
address this problem yeah great thanks
Marv